en un edificio de los pocos que quedó
destruido esa ciudad que no fue de las
más afectadas pero en la que se ha
habido muchos muertos este edificio por
ejemplo Hace unos días era una montaña
enorme de escombros ahora ya no es así
porque según nos explicaba uno de los
miembros de este equipo de rescate que
de hecho tenía familiares viviendo en
este edificio ahora mismo las tareas de
demolición de los restos y de rescate
las personas que estaban atrapadas han
llegado ya al suelo antiguo del edificio
todo lo que rodea las escaleras
centrales del edificio y ha sido
excavado y de allí ha sido sacadas todas
las personas os explicaba este miembro
del Equipo de rescate que en el edificio
consideran las autoridades turcas que
había en el momento del terremoto cerca
de unos 90-95 personas hasta la fecha
han encontrado 70 cuerpos en el interior
aquí de aquí no ha salido nadie con vida
consideran que a la misma quedan unas 20
personas de las cuales cuatro han sacado
ahora mismo pero ya han encontrado los
cadáveres
explican Que las próximas horas podrán
sacarlos Porque ahora mismo están
atrapados esta persona de hecho nos
contaba Cómo se derriba un edificio ese
tipo tan alto este edificio tenía 16
pisos y ocurre un aspecto extraño que es
en la base del edificio si parte una
calle que es la primera que cede durante
el terremoto todo el edificio se derriba
en espiral porque en las partes del
edificio intentan ocupar el espacio que
va cediendo la pared y las bases que van
cayendo y así por ejemplo él explicaba
que su su familiar que vive aquí vivía
en la fachada norte de la ciudad y su
piso sus muebles y el cadáver de su
familiar ha sido encontrado en la
fachada sur de la Ciudad ahora mismo las
tareas de rescate se centran sobre todo
en las escaleras centrales de este
edificio donde se quedó atrapada las 20
personas que se supone que quedan en el
interior quedaron atrapadas ahí después
de que intentasen salir de este edificio
en el momento que se robó hemos visto
incluso imágenes de Google Maps que
pueden ser encontradas en la aplicación
de internet en las que se ve el cuando
estaban y tenía ya rasguños y daños
bastante fuertes lo que puede demostrar
que muchos edificios en esta región no
estaban preparados para un terremoto y
una sacudida de este tamaño según
explican muchos vecinos la seguridad fue
brutal y lo derribó absolutamente todo
no en esa ciudad en esta ciudad todo
aguantado Pero hay otras provincias muy
afectadas en el caso por ejemplo de
Hawai la ciudad de Antioquia según
explican sus propios habitantes ha
perdido cerca del 90% de los edificios
el 90% ha quedado completamente
derribado el 10% que queda está tan
dañado que ahora sus edificios ya no son
para nada utilizables